begin by reading you a little section
from a book that was written by Anna
Louise strong an American activist and
journalist who visited Central Asia in
the early 1920s and she wrote a book
very much in the genre of excitement on
the part of some American leftists I was
seeing the Soviet Union as a great
prospect for a new model of statehood
and the book wasn't called the first
time in history I'm going to read it a
bit from a chapter on education in
soviet russia as it's called and it
reads as follows some delegates of the
Uzbek nation came to Moscow we want to
teach her students Institute they said
it's a prosaic demand but it covers the
wildest romance of Education that
perhaps the world has ever seen you you
you have never heard of those becks
neither have I neither has anyone except
a few anthropologists who study the half
wild tribes between Europe and Asia some
eight or ten of these people doubtless
sons of privilege chieftains once
penetrated far enough into the world to
learn Russian and receive a higher
education it isn't surprising that you
and I missed those eight or ten in the
days of the star those backs had not
discovered the alphabet it follows that
they had no textbooks no one since the
world began ever learned to read or
write in news back but then came the
Russian Revolution well she's very
excited and she's very enthusiastic
obviously about the revolution she's a
bit misinformed about central asian
there's bags in fact those bikes did
have writing in fact for the Russians
did perhaps so I mean it's hard to
define when the news Beck's began
writing but because the in specs have a
complicated history but but it's
certainly not the case that civilization
was brought to to Central Asia by the
Russians though that is one of the
narratives that has dominated the 20th
century in particular and in some of the
well of course the enthusiasm for the
Soviet project that
that we saw in the 20th century as well
now I'm asked to talk to you about the
the re-emergence of Central Asia and the
Caucasus as a field of study in a region
that Americans focus on and of course
that's probably referring primarily to
wet this happened since the breakup of
the Soviet Union it was possible to ask
your average American what they know
about who's Becca Stan and they'll say
absolutely nothing it still is probably
possible to ask many Americans the same
question and get the same answer but
about the situation has changed quite a
bit and Uzbekistan is Todd as a subject
in elementary schools in social studies
the classes and so on so the world has
changed but it's not the first time that
that Central Asia has emerged as a
region that has caught the world's
attention and I will take you to a few
of those previous moments in history and
in talking about those moments I want to
talk about the way that that the
interest in this region has governed the
way that we think about it and what
kinds of issues arise and the the
frameworks for analysis that have
affected the way that that the region is
understood often in not very helpful
ways I think in terms of trying to
understand what what the region is all
about and a good example of that is this
quote that I gave you from Anna Louise
strong who clearly had an agenda in
trying to paint the the Central Asians
is very backward and and distant from
civilization and in desperate need of
modernization this kind of this kind of
assessment of Central Asia has been
characteristic particularly since the
Russian advance into the region so
preceding Soviet rule in the region and
has served as in many parts of the world
where colonialism has come about as a
rationale for the so-called ridiculous
spread of civilization into the region
brought by European powers so but that
is but one of the agendas that that I'll
be talking about today
before if I can get this thing to work
okay before before I do that I want to
present to you the geography that I know
that probably most of you are not
primarily focused on this part of the
world don't have the map and etched on
your brains like I do and and to situate
the the region in terms of the
frameworks that we think about it as
well first of all here you have a map of
Eurasia or at least part of your age
it's chopping off the western part of
Eurasia at least by one definition this
is what Eurasia meant to me when I was
in going to school it was Europe and
Asia together two big continents or
really just one land mass it has of
course through history had a variety of
different meanings and I'll come back to
that in a moment but if we want to talk
about Central Asia so the region that
I'm going Central Asia and the Caucasus
and such places the regions that I'm
going to focus on primarily today of
course where the center is of a big
continent is a bit hard to find as well
and the term Central Asia has been
applied to different parts of this this
region in the last century or so many
british authors considered central asia
to be primarily mongolia and west
western china so a region much more much
further east than what I'll be talking
about primarily today in its come to
have a settled meaning focused on the
five stands so the what I'll have a
closer map in a moment of that but the
west western part of what is some kind
of times called inner asia also and so
the five former Soviet republics but of
course this is a rather arbitrary
definition in many ways because the
peoples that inhabit these regions
spread across the borders and I'll show
you a picture of that as well the fact
that these this part was part of the
Soviet Union was an artifact of Russian
colonial expansion into the region and
of course it had a huge impact on the
way that the world is understood today
both within and outside of the region
but at the same time western China for
example machine Zhang region northern
Afghanistan the other by John is divided
between Iran and and the four
Soviet republic and so on these are all
places where there's much there's it's
quite arbitrary where the borders are
drawn and sorry okay yeah so just
zooming in a bit here actually I'll move
on to the next amount for interest the
time okay so to begin with some terms we
have in the the title of this summer
institute we have the term Eurasia and
as i noted it has a variety of different
meanings which have been changing
rapidly over the past couple decades as
well as i noted the first definition
that i encountered was just the
combination of two land masses or one
really why do one landmass Europe and
Asia together but there's an also an old
meaning of Eurasia that goes back to in
Russian history Russian thinking that
situates Eurasia as a kind of a counter
position in relation to to Europe so
it's the part of Europe that's really
more asian than Europe is I suppose one
way to think about this and the part of
the landmass that connects with eastern
places and that connects with another
concept which has become quite popular
in the post-soviet period particularly
in places like Kazakhstan where there's
a notion of a region which brings
together both Europe and Asia so it's
not fully European and it doesn't have
to be it doesn't have to follow a
European model at but at the same time
it opens doors to Asia for Europe and
things like that and Kazakhstan itself
is officially bridging between I mean
geographically bridging because the
western part is in what is officially
known as Europe being west of the ER all
river and and so there's this idea of
something that's that's not fully
European and it's okay that that's not
but also opens doors to Asia and
connects with places further east that's
something that's become quite common and
these are all things that figure into
the current imaginations of the region
as well that is how Central Asians and
want to think of themselves as connected
with other parts of the world there's of
course another definition of Eurasia
which has become quite common and that's
basically euphemism for the former
Soviet Union we don't want to use a
negative category like the former Soviet
Union so we say your age instead but of
course it has the same semantic impact
ultimately because we're failing to
define something in any other way
besides the fact that it's it's the
former Soviet Union in that context and
in another way that this figures for
example in the center where I work Davis
center for russian and eurasian Studies
at Harvard the Eurasia of course is the
the rest of the of the former Soviet
Union so everything besides Russia and
it particularly tends to be thought of
as the southern part so set the Central
Asian the Caucasus the parts that I'll
be talking about primarily today but
again this is sort of a negative
definition of taking out Russia out of
the framework of concepts and then yet
another idea that that is used as a way
of appealing to a new kind of unity
across the region and a rationale for
building links that connect for example
the Muslim regions of the former Soviet
Union not with Islam but rather with
something that really is the former
Soviet Union but a rationale for for
instance reintegrating that that space
that fell apart in 1991-92 there are
other terms that relate to the to the
region that I'll be talking about today
and these are very dynamically moving
terms terms that it's often hard to pin
down on maps the the primary one being
Central Asia and Central Asia has been
drawn very broadly sometimes very
narrowly when I first established the
program on Central Asia at Harvard I
just called it Central Asia and
everything from the Crimea to Mongolia
sort of very broad definition but the
problem with that of course is that some
of these people don't want to be called
Central Asians but for example in the
Caucasus they don't think of themselves
as being Central Asia although for
example the
one of the major journals in this field
Central Asian survey has always
considered the Caucasus to be just as
much part of its territory as his other
parts so there's a sort of an ambivalent
relationship to the term Central Asia in
the russian-speaking context prior to
nineteen ninety-one the there were two
terms which you could encounter once
fading as you sometimes translated I
think rather oddly into English as
middle asia and that is it what in the
russian context it was usually referred
to as central asian and kazakhstan so
basically it's the five republics that
we now tend to call central asia plus
but separating Kazakhstan out of Central
Asia and there's some ambivalence about
whether Kazakhstan properly belongs in
that context but interestingly after
1991 especially in Kazakhstan itself and
but in throughout the region there's
been a desire to reconcile in the term
central nasia which in Russian context
used to mean not this area that is not
not the stands the western part of
Central Asia at all but rather Mongolia
and places like that Gobi Desert is
being the center of central asia but in
in the post-soviet period there's been a
desire to we re conceptualize and this
has led to a concept of this term
central Niyazi which includes not
sometimes not just the five former
soviet republics but also afghanistan
some in some contexts as well as western
china and of course the way that it's
defined in my talk today is central
asian the caucasus which tends to narrow
the definition of central asia to do not
include the caucasus of course and
perhaps not to include other places as
well but i will be talking about things
that that connect beyond these
boundaries to some extent is so for
example the muslim other muslim regions
of russia which are neither central asia
of the caucasus by this by this
definition the caucasus being what is
you otherwise known as the southern
Caucasus the north caucasus now being
part of Russia and and then yet another
term in
Asia which was put forward by Dennis
sign or I'll talk a little bit about him
more about him later which which takes
in everything which but when he was he
was Hungarian and he was very interested
in the unity of of things Finnick and a
Greek and Turkish and Mongolian
considered that this was all 11 family
in fact probably he he believed that the
Koreans and Japanese were part of the
same family as well so this great huge
territory extending all the way from
Finland and hungry to to Manchuria and
then perhaps also Korea and Japan was
unified into a concept of that that
actually created the the inner asian and
I'll take Studies department at Indiana
as part of its legacy since renamed the
Department of Central Asian Studies and
that leads me to the last term on the
list here central Eurasia which when it
first appeared in the right around 90 91
was when I really started about making
an impact I didn't like it it seemed
like just another euphemism for for the
rump Soviet Union basically and but then
I I was elected president of the center
of the Asian Studies society and I that
the idea started to grow grow on me mean
it was a new society at the time and I
thought this is not the right name for
it but actually it works quite well and
I would encourage everyone to consider
this as a good way to designate the the
region because it has the advantage of
being ill defined first of all and
therefore you can you can define it you
can create you can create terms for
defining it and the the Caucasians
people from the Caucasus are very keen
to go to the Central Eurasian studies
Society conference but they wouldn't
have gone to a central asian studies
conference for example so so it goes to
show how emotions also play into into
the way that people think about these
concepts and I don't want to spend too
much time on this map
I'm not seeing ok so here we have the
very sharply colored map of the of
Central Asia in the Caucasus countries
so there's five Central Asian states
this being what used to be called cydia
as you the southern part and then
kazakhstan was added in now all this is
tend to be referred to as central naazia
plus the Caucasus so three southern
southern Caucasus Republic's south of
the the Caucasus mountain range here and
of course what that does is cuts off the
North Caucasus which in many ways is
very closely connected with that region
and it cuts off other things which I'll
show you on another map in the moment
but of course one of the ways that we
tend to think about this region is not
so much about about geography but about
who the people are that lived there and
this is one way to cut or to describe
the medicine to think about their
religious affiliation and indeed this
has been one of the dominant frameworks
for thinking about this part of the
world since Soviet times that is to
think about it is the Muslim part of the
former Soviet Union or the Soviet Union
at the time and what you have on this
map is the the density or the percentage
of population who are Muslims according
to the lasts or window last Soviet
census the second-to-last Soviet yeah
the second-to-last Soviet census and the
the darker colors are very dense Muslim
populations where I mean this is a
little bit less and then as you go
further north towards the Arctic Circle
you get small percentages of the
population of course doesn't mean
there's a lot of Muslims up in the
Arctic Circle they're just part of the
same administrative unit that the this
map is is marking out but there actually
are quite a few Muslims in the Arctic
Circle now because of labor migration
and this began already during Soviet
times friends in northern tajikistan who
throughout soviet I mean throughout the
late soviet period and into the
present have been going off to to menta
to pump oil in in shifts of weeks at a
time and another place that on this
matter should be marked as Moscow itself
because of course there's a huge Muslim
population in Moscow and in other cities
there wasn't Soviet times and there is
now as well the of course this way of
thinking about things divides the
Caucasus so you have the Christian
Caucasus and the Muslim Caucasus
Azerbaijan and and the Northern Caucasus
being predominantly Muslim populations
especially in the Western at the eastern
part Georgia and Armenia being Christian
even more so now than they were during
Soviet times because of the flights of
population between Republic's now this
map shows the different way of thinking
about the world and I'm not sure
actually I don't really quite understand
what they're trying to do with this map
but it gives an example of how people
have tried to reconcile Asia's position
within the wider world here we have a
map that connects Kenya and Kazakhstan
not something that the people in
Kazakhstan would probably be that keen
to to do I mean they don't see
themselves as being belonging to that
same part of the world but I think it
reflects also this way of thinking about
the world is as being vulnerable to
Islam actually I mean that's what this
map is about is the way that Islam can
extend from fundamentalist states in
Sudan Anna and other parts of the
Islamic world and connect and pose a
certain kind of danger for for Central
Asia as well well the color the fact
that it's not gray means that they're
trying to focus on this region but the
rest of the colors are just I think
mapmakers choice of a good pattern
but taking us back to the Soviet context
of the Christmas is the Soviet Union and
and what you see here is is I mean what
comes out clearly on this map is that
there are certain areas where where it's
not Russia so starting with Kazakhstan
which actually looks a lot like Russia
for some reason and the coloring of the
map but this is northern northern
boundary of Kazakhstan maybe because
there's so many Russians there other
Europeans here but so these areas end up
being a region unto themselves in this
in this as the world appears on this
framework and let me focus in a bit on
that so you have these the Central Asian
Republics but beyond the the southern
Caucasus which I pointed out before you
have a number of small territories you
see marked out here which are also with
Muslim inhabited predominantly or at
least formerly many of them have now
been overrun by migrants from other
parts of Russia and here's the map of
Republic's as that it stood at the end
of the the Soviet time if we look at the
world now though in the Caucasus region
the actual control of Armenia extends
well into the territory of Azerbaijan
for example so this map doesn't quite
show them the the real picture and of
course Russia has now basically an extre
come close to annexing southern si Tia
and Abkhazia so the map is changing in
some ways most people don't most
countries don't recognize that those
changes but the facts on the ground
certainly speak to dramatic change
that's going on in the region but the
the situation in the Caucasus is is
extremely complicated linguistically and
and in terms of the distribution of
populations that you can get a bit of a
sense of that from from this map here
the greenish colors represent Turkic
population so along the Caspian coast
and extending down to to Iran of course
this part of Iran is predominantly
turkey population as well also called
John then you have the Armenians and
these bluish colors are various Iranian
groups which include the settings which
extend from the northern caucasus in
Russia into that territory that had
pointed out a moment ago in in Georgia
and then various Caucasian groups which
speak very difficult to learn languages
and one of the things that that makes
the study of this part of the world
really difficult is the fact that
there's such a huge diversity of
different languages spoken many of them
are very difficult to learn in fact
probably most of them are and and very
few people learn more than a couple of
them so where I can claim to be a
specialist on Central Asia in a broad
sense I've learned tajuk and so Iranian
language family member have learned
turkey cake so that takes me to the rest
of Central Asia but people who can make
that kind of claim about the Caucasus
are very few in there linguists that is
it really complicates it and it changes
the picture for the study of the region
as well because it means that mostly the
people who study armenia for example are
people who are really focused on armenia
and are not interested in azerbaijan
except as their enemy and and they're
not that keen on the Georgians either
although they're christians as well and
orthodox christians but but there's lots
of tensions between those those two
countries as well and as a result view
you have specialists who really focus on
one or another part of the region and
very few people who can address it in a
broad way I myself starting to work more
in Georgia but the prospect of actually
learning Georgian language is very
daunting don't know if I'll ever
actually manage to do that this map
shows that this is a technic map made by
the CIA they made some wonderfully
colorful maps right at the end of the
Soviet period and one thing that you can
see from this map I mean you can see
this the southern Soviet boundary here
run across the map here and then
way but one thing that you see is that
that the population groups in these
areas are extend across the boundaries
in ways that make the boundary is not
really very meaningful in terms of
dividing or uniting ethnic population so
there's more tajuk's in Afghanistan
actually than there are in Tajikistan
there's a very large number of booze
bags the screen color there's Beck's in
Afghanistan and as I noted before as IV
in out in other by pinner on Ian
Azerbaijan well outnumber the the odds
of the other by johnnys in Azerbaijan so
the boundaries are a rather artificial
in those terms but of course the the
world has changed dramatically since
those boundaries were established that
is the southern boundary as I'll show
you in a map in a moment was the result
of the Russian expansion into the region
but this 20th century and so we
experienced so dramatically transformed
this region that people in Tajikistan
although they know that there's more
tajuk's and Afghanistan there are intent
on they don't think those are the same
people at all there they think of them
as very different and now what I want to
do is just talk about the transformation
that that this region has undergone in
recent times of course the world has not
always been like it is now with this
region really being under Russians wing
Russia's wing and if you look at this
map you see Western cuttery for example
is in the center of the map i know that
is very legible and the the yellow at
the top of the map is is is Russia
actually I think I have a better version
of this map in a moment but it but if
you try to put these two maps together
of course it's very difficult there's no
virtually no boundaries that that that
map shows the situation at the beginning
of the 20 of the 19th century the end of
the 20th century there's virtually no
boundaries that that are uncommon so as
the states have emerged the in their
current forms of course that has led to
all kinds of
information so this this claim that the
specs didn't have an alphabet I suppose
you could actually almost make that
claim to some extent if you focus on
certain news bags if you chase I was
back history back in a certain way then
you might might be able to find those
whose bags it didn't have an alphabet
but there was there was no common entity
that logically became was becca Stan as
of 1924 when this becca ston was
established it was something that had to
be created at that time and has been in
the process of creation ever since so
the creating and his beck identity
really was something quite new as of
1925 when Anna Louise strong was writing
her comment on that ok so yes oh so
here's that that map in it is fuller
extent and one thing I just like to note
about this map is that though though the
map represents the situation after
wretched expansion into the region it's
not really conceptualizes as the same
thing as rush you have European Russia
which is not colored on this map and
then the Asian parts of Russia are
colored in these various colors and
interestingly western pottery which had
just become part of russia these parts
of it had become rush part of russia at
the time was making of this map is
colored all in red although there's
actually quite a diversity of
territories here there's a this is
western China of today's western China
this is these are the still then
independent states of bukhara and kiva
whether the labels are okay sure so
Western Western totora reeds here you
can see just the beginning of the word
hatari which is from Eastern pottery for
the eastern part of this map that large
word up there I wish I had a long longer
arm it is is orenburg so that's the
southern Russian outpost from where sent
the expansion into Central Asia was
taking place this is Turk Turk menya
which actually is one of the few terms
that you would find on a map from this
time and also into contemporary time now
called turkmenistan of course but but it
wasn't a state at that time it was just
a territory where of the Turkmen hurt
that yeah that's actually used right up
till today by some people and that
refers to the the other side of the
Caucasus Mountains trans being via
beyond right and there's also something
called sis Caucasus very seldom used
which refers to the Northern Caucasus so
the in the stalls of course from the
perspective of Russia whenever you have
a turn transmits its in relation
somebody's point of reference and
actually have forgotten but I can I can
dig it out yeah it's a British man yeah
this is the translation of guberniya in
Russian which is one of the most of the
Russia was divided into guberniya as
territories within Russia but Central
Asia this time was not formally
incorporated into Russia was still a
military territory and and only only
towards the end of the 19th century
became began to become incorporated
the map with it represents the situation
in the first half of the other of the
19th century I think it was made in the
second half of the 19th century but it
was meant as a historical map and here
you have a map which shows the expansion
of Russia into Central Asia I won't show
you the map of Russian expansion into
into the Caucasus which happened
basically just before the events that
are represented on this map and as you
can see starting at the end of the
eighteenth centuries of the dates at the
top of the amount of our 18th century
dates in the middle of the 18th century
Russia began expanding into the into the
step region and gained a loose control
over what's now Kazakhstan through
basically agreements with the Kazakh
leaders what came to be under Soviet
rule called the free willing
incorporation of the Kazakhs into the
Russian state this was the formulaic
term but of course those cosmic didn't
really mean that they they were going to
be part of the Soviet Union eventually
that was not their plan it was just a
way of getting the Russians off their
back and it didn't really mean much
because this was very loosely controlled
territory by anyone it was very sparsely
populated and so on but as as Russia
gained more consolidate control over the
Caucasus they began focusing more on
Central Asia and by the mid part of that
of the 19th century so it dates like
1864 you have expansion into the more
densely populated regions of southern
central asia places like Tashkent
captured in 1865 coke on which was the
center of one of the major ha needs of
the region in 1876 Samarkand and Bukhara
within the car enumerate and so on and
and so as I'll note a bit later this was
the time when Russia was starting to get
quite close to rush the British
territories in in the southern part of
Asia and we have what I mean this period
of time is come to be called the great
game the period of
posted competition within the region
between these two expanding imperial
powers and the the last dates on this
map are the very end of the 19th century
when when Russia and Britain were making
deals and they sent joint expeditions up
to these very remote regions for example
where they made made agreements about
where the boundaries would fall in
territories which were very remote from
their control actually but they they
made these decisions ultimately they
decided that that Russia should not have
a common boundary with with Britain and
so they made the Wakhan corridor which
extends its the eastern bit of
Afghanistan which extends between the
bulk of Afghanistan and China so so this
was all a part of the the Imperial
process of expansion into the region and
this map shows the sorry ok good this
shows how it was gradually incorporated
within the Russian state so here you
have the wood or not this is actually it
was called in Russian turkestan ski cry
so that the Russian terrorists on
territory their various other cries
around the edges of the Russian Empire
and they were incorporated on the
somewhat different basis from most of
the administrative structure of the
Russian Empire itself but it is this
time you also have the emirate of
bukhara and the khanate of khiva here
which retained independence right up
until the revolution though they were
heavily dominated by Russia and with for
example trade agreements which required
them to do trade with with Russia not
with blade places in south and so on but
but Russia had very limited capacity in
this region at this time and right up
until the early 20th century there were
limited numbers of Russians in the
southern part of Central Asia and and I
think Russia fell very far away at the
time
quickly just in the interest of time
okay so so these are 19th century maps
and you see here the situation again a
map which shows european russia is being
distinct from from the asian part of
russian you have asian russia here
marked in yellow and interestingly they
don't mark eva and Bukhara as being
independent state so the fact that they
were independent really didn't mean too
much to the european mac makers at that
time and of course the whole process of
conceptualizing what kind of space that
this is it was one that developed
gradually have a wonderful map of this
region which represents the region in
medieval times and their big areas that
are just marked terra incognita they
admitted that they didn't know what
what's going on daunting me here okay
and then in 1924 you have the creation
of the Republic's more or less as they
they are today that is there was a
process that extended from 1924 until
the end of the night 1930s during which
basically all the soviet socialist
republics of say for example kyrgyzstan
or Kyrgyz soviet socialist republic
Uzbek etc they were established and the
process by which they were established
was an interesting one but I already
showed you how complicated the the
ethnic map of the region is and indeed
it's very complicated and and yet they
were trying to represent the ethnic
distribution in some way they decided
that they would base this division on
national characteristics as they were
defined at the time of course most the
people didn't know what nation they
belong to there wasn't a concept of a
nation that that matched up with what
Stalin and and
the policymakers in Moscow wanted to
create i mean the the Union of Soviet
Socialist Republics Soviet Socialist
Republics based on and as a result you
got very interesting things like the
creation of Uzbekistan we're a very
large part of that was black population
where people at that time who would have
said I'm not who's back those those
people are his bags we're not as back at
all and it's only been gradually that
people have come to accept the
designations which which were given and
that's further complicated by the fact
that the their distribution on the
ground was quite mosaic lake and in some
way this map you can emphasize is how
what kind of a mosaic it was and how
they seemed to be trying to grab bits of
population to include them in one or
another Republic yes
it's not in any way equivalent to that
and part of the reason is because well
at the time of the partition in South
Asia everyone knew whether they were
Muslim or non-muslim right so they knew
where they they fit into this framework
but it was much more ambiguous when they
created these these Republic's and and
there were many groups which actually
could have gone either way at the time
and one a good example of that is the
Kipchaks who in have a big part of what
you see on this map and they were
eventually officially decided to be
those backs but they speak a language
which is rather close to Kyrgyz and even
to this day the Kipchaks reb would
rather have their daughters Mary Kyrgyz
than booze Beck's because they're
culturally closer but they know that
they're who's Beck's officially so so
there's much more ambiguity there were
some movements of population in for
example in the case of the capital of
Tajikistan which that's dushawn Bay
which was a village of about 250 people
at the time that it would became the
capital there was they gave no city to
to the first version of Tajikistan and
as a result they had to create a capital
and they invited a lot of Tajikistan
mark on which fell in was Becca Stan to
come to to to form that new capital so a
very large part of the population of of
Bashan bay is actually some work on DS
than people from other other cities and
they they retain these identities and
they retain to some extent links with
with places where where they came from
already nearly a century ago or 80 90
years ago but when one thing that I want
to emphasize about this map is that
though it's very regulated right the
boundaries are it seemed to be grabbing
bits of population but they don't always
do logical things like this bit I mean
this is the red is becca ston right but
this bit is actually a Tajik Enclave and
they gave it to his background run no
reasons it's actually very close to
Tajikistan so they could easily have
connected it with tajikistan then the
next thing they did was this is the
1930s version of the map
next thing I did was actually take this
territory give it to Kyrgyzstan create
an island here this is also an island
and and so you have even more
complicated boundaries than were
established in this first version of the
boundaries of the time but the other
thing to note about this is that the
boundaries hardly mattered until
nineteen ninety one they they were
internal boundaries within Soviet Union
had some economic administrative
significance but for the most part
people really didn't even know where the
boundaries were and I did a lot of work
in the Fergana Valley actually in the in
the mid-1990s so significantly after the
breakup of the Soviet Union people still
didn't know where the boundaries were
they didn't know what Republic they were
right now independent country they were
living in just after that they started
putting big fences and mines and things
like that around the borders of
Uzbekistan so people started to know
very well where the boundaries fell and
sometimes it just cut right in the
middle of a house these houses actually
got to be useful monetary sources
because you could sneak people through
the boundary so there are lots of ways
to get across the boundaries that beyond
the the the very controlled efforts of
the state's tried to establish in the in
the late 1990s yes
he maintained his interest and two was
there interested not drawing it along
ethnic lines to dissipate nationalism
yeah well you write that sound was the
commissar of nationalities and he's
generally considered to be the author of
the idea the general Soviet idea of what
nationality should be in what role they
should play in the construction of the
Soviet Union although in many ways his
ideas about national nationalism were
very standard run-of-the-mill ideas may
they were what was current at the time
in general but but actually just before
this 1924 division they had drawn up a
completely different map that made no
reference to distributions of ethnic
populations and we're going to do it
along those that divide things along
those lines they decided eventually and
nobody's properly investigated why that
they would make this kind of division
about whether they were trying to
dissipate or unite there's actually
quite a lot of interesting discourse
about this which fits into Cold War
discourses that I'll talk about a bit
more later but the gist of it is that
that there's a claim that that this
effort to mark out territories was
actually a divide and rule strategy that
is these people really just unified and
didn't distinguish themselves in the way
that the Soviet state encouraged them
later to do and by dividing things this
way it was a way of preventing Turkey
predominantly Turkic unified turkey
population and Muslim population from
standing as a significant counterweight
to to the Soviet project of development
and transformation of the region there's
very little evidence to support that
claim that is that it was a divide and
rule strategy but it certainly figures
very strongly in the way that Westerners
thought about the this whole process of
the transformation of Central Asia right
up until the end of the Soviet Union but
the I mean of course they're also
uniting people and creating new
identities which conceivably could
become the basis of nationalism
and the kind of thing that you were
suggesting they would want to dissipate
of course at that time they didn't there
was nothing to dissipate there wasn't
any strong nationalism was Beck's for
example so there was no danger of that
at the time but but but but these kind
of this tension that you've identified
it certainly plays importantly into the
way that people think about the region
throughout subsequent times now just if
but I want to focus in again on the
Fergana Valley region which was what the
previous map was presenting and to put
it in context and this is a map made by
a Hungarian Explorer of the region at
the end of the actually I think it's the
very first years of the 20th century and
his name is we fall V and Hungarians
were very interested in this part of the
region part of the world for the reasons
that I mentioned earlier that they
thought of these is their ethnic
brothers the Hungarians being together
with the Turks in this broad euro Altaic
linguistic family and so the various
Hungarian explorers went off the Central
Asia including this guy who made rather
detailed ethnographic maps and the
Fergana Valley region which I mentioned
earlier is this area here so surrounded
by the mountains which are makeup
kyrgyzstan you could almost see
Kyrgyzstan today that is this big swath
of yellow territory which surrounds the
Fergana Valley but one thing that's
interesting here is that this red on the
map is is Taji population so iranian
speakers and this is not tajikistan in
today's in the resulting tajikistan
that's actually a part of uzbekistan and
there are various other anomalies that i
could point out to you on the map so
that the idea that this is this the the
effort to map or to create a map that
that matched ethnic populations is
actually quite mean it's quite tenuous
in many ways so as i mentioned before
this this whole area of northern Fergana
Valley is marked as it's probably
exaggerated how many techs there are
there but they're certainly very many
tajuk's even today
a that all became miss Becca ston and
then we have yet the same kind of issue
appearing on maps that are made much
more recently that is the the match
between ethnic populations and and
different kinds of groups this is a map
that was made by the CIA also in
nineteen nineteen ninety so just on the
eve of the breakup of the Soviet Union
and they were trying to identify to the
Western policy audience where the
problems would be in Central Asia the
things that they really focused in on
were where things like these anomalies
of territory and population so for
example if you one of these things will
pop out it's not working like supposed
to ok so I'll ignore the pop outs but so
for example they focus on bukhara in
summer Conte which are situated in is
becca ston but have tajuk population and
this is understood to be a really big
problem for for for the region because
how good tajuk's want to live within
with becca's on boat it's actually not
not a problem at all at least not like
that there's also for example in the
northern can shun they draw up this tear
this hot spot here of the interface
between Kyrgyz and kha'zix and also a
lot of Russian migrants to the region
with the idea that Rushton migrants and
care get some Cossacks will will come
into conflict that's also not been an
issue of conflict so the way that the
region has been conceptualized and I
think this is in part as a result of the
what actually happened in the in the
Caucasus where you did have very violent
conflict that had a nuh care achter to
it in Central Asia these these constant
Lakes barely happened there were few
conflicts and I don't want to minimize
their importance but but nothing on the
scale of what you had in the Caucasus
and yet that's the kind of what problem
of the way that people were thinking
about the region but as I noted before
until nineteen ninety that there was
there the boundaries existed but people
hardly paid attention to where they were
and
didn't have that much significance papel
trial coming up behind the map for the
million
sorry I had wonderful but one were
wonderful effects here that are simply
not working I usually tried to pry plug
my own computer into the isn't just
going to loop here now they don't like
what I'm saying about them okay so now
just to give you one last sort of
geographic presentation of the region
and to bring you or to bring myself into
the picture in a moment this is the this
is you see the relief map of the central
asian region and on this map you can see
it's a really quite a large territory if
my effects work here okay so here's
france and so compared with france it's
really quite large in just kazakhstan
this is probably about for France's and
but but the the great majority the
population is concentrated in the
southeastern part of Central Asia the
northern parts of what you see marked
out here is the is the is step region so
it's a continuation of the great
Eurasian steppe which extends to the
Mongolia and hungry on the other end
another reason why the Hungarians are so
keen on Central Asia and and this is a
grassland and traditionally hurting
territory now these two areas that I
marked out our our desert regions
they're very dry deserts where very very
little as possible to survive and also
hurting regions traditionally
territories where you really had to move
your herds quickly because they would
exhaust the fodder very quickly and move
between between wells so that you could
give them water and then then the third
Geographic the type of for Central Asia
is this southeastern area of mountain
regions which include the pamir and Ally
regions here as well as the tension
which are all extensions of major
mountain region mountain systems that
extend into China and the border of
south asia and these are some of the
highest mountains in the world really
very dramatic i come from colorado
originally and thought I came from a
mountainous territory but
not compared with not when compared with
these areas where I worked now the
circles that you see appearing on the
map now show places that I've spent time
doing fieldwork I'm an anthropologist
and I spend my time talking with people
on the ground and so we'll take it very
good 11 okay and and showing some of the
places that I've worked and these
represent some of the urban centers
where I've worked there's also oh sorry
here we close zooming in on the region
where I've spent most of the time so
this is the southeastern part of Central
Asia these are all places where I've
spent some some significant amounts of
time has been up altogether about five
or six years in in fieldwork in Central
Asia and they include urban centers
actually I'll mattel do it has a star
now is no longer the capital of
Kazakhstan made moved it astana further
north in the country but these are the
the concentrations of the most sort of
intensive Soviet ization of the region
you have other urban centers where I
work including some are Conte and or
shear the eastern and the Fergana Valley
which because they were not Republican
capitals were allowed to develop in a
more sort of organic way less less
heavily transformed by the Soviet
project and then I've worked in a lot of
rural areas as well the next pictures
will show you just some of the
landscapes of places where I worried
this actually might then when your old
daughter we were up doing field work on
the border with China in Kyrgyzstan and
this is in the high mountains of
Tajikistan this spectacular area where
there's actually no road into this area
at the very end of the Soviet period
they did one of their very last
deportations of population taking the
entire population out of this region
forcing them to to do agricultural work
on lowlands and at the time when I
visited it right around nineteen ninety
they were just being allowed to come
back that some people were allowed we're
coming back so you have a place like
this also on the fringes of the mountain
ranges and indeed most of the population
is concentrated around the edges of the
mountain
or on the rivers which flow out of the
mountains which is of course where
there's water to sustain life this is in
the northern edge of the the Turkish on
range just on the western boundary of
the Fergana Valley and you see why you
see here is they're growing rice of all
things it's very dry dry part of the
world but they love their rice and in
fact they love local rice better than
anything imported so they they still
grow it but most of the agriculture is
concentrated on cotton production and
what you see here is a field that's been
harvested of cotton and now the sheep
are eating the stubble so there's a lot
of sheep in Central Asia as well that no
sheep intimately doing field work there
and this view is looking northwards
towards the tan Shan Mountains it so
this picture is in Uzbekistan but
looking towards Kyrgyzstan and Fergana
Valley and then you have ancient urban
capitals like Samarqand here this
picture I took at the end of the Soviet
Union before they done a lot of the
renovation work now they've completely
built mostly rebuild most of these
monuments so they look like they were
built yesterday I think they've lost a
lot of their their their character and
and then this is also a late soviet
picture from from Tashkent what was
represented urban modernization at the
time of course they have even much more
urban modernized things now lots of
glass buildings in Tashkent trying to
look very modern now I wasn't the first
person to send visit Central Asia and I
wasn't one of those few anthropologists
that that Anna Lewis strong was
referring to that knew that there were
such things as Uzbek one of the early
visitors if I could have been a whole
series of interesting travel logs that
you can dig into from from early visits
going back to dark Marco Polo and others
that visited this region the fur for
what seemed like obvious reasons of the
time that this is the center of some of
the biggest most powerful states of
of the world this this what represents
the Embassy of Regan solace de Chloe ho
from from Spain so at the very beginning
of the of the 15th century he went off
to visit tamerlane escort team were the
court of two more who was then one of
the greatest me know they hope the ruler
over one of the largest empires of the
world of the time and he he wrote an
account which you can you can dig into
he visited bukhara and some are can't of
course many many other places along the
way it went through the southern
Caucasus on the way and he gives us an
account of this actually maybe this is a
good moment to take a pause like that
and we'll take a break so I will take it
you into more of these the history of
more of these people going into Central
Asian coming to know it at when we
resume well after after this visit in
the early 15th century of course as I
mentioned there have been many many
other travelers to the region and
they've all been connected with ideas
about why the region is important I mean
one of the reasons why we hear about
them is because they wrote about it and
they were trying to sell their their
story and so the question is well what
kind of story about this region sells
what what is important to a Western
audience and particular an American
audience as we're thinking about it here
of course at this time there was no
American audience but it's interestingly
connected with America this is just on
the eve of the the reconquest of
southern Spain by the Christians and and
then the emergence of Spain as a as a
world power and obviously the sending of
an embassy to another world power at
that time represents something about
Spain's ambitions and here you see the
map of his journey I pause on that the
there there were other moments in
history when the Central Asia drew
attention but probably most prominently
the next moment would would have been
that period of the great game that I
mentioned earlier the period of Russian
expansion southwards which raised the
alarm in in the British Empire about the
potential for conflict over
Asian territories and the concern about
the possibility of a common boundary and
conflicts between the Russian Empire and
the British Empire and and one of the
most prominent figures writing about
this matter was this gentleman at Thomas
Mario sorry Charles Marvin who wrote a
number of very popular books in Britain
he's British and this one is the Russian
advanced towards towards India all of
them had the character of sort of an
alarmist message that we really need to
worry about what these Russians are
doing and but the I think that this
conception of what the Russians were
doing is somehow threatening Britain and
British interests is probably rather
exaggerated some people talk about
reviving the the concept of the rate
great game as a framework for analyzing
what's going on now in Central Asia and
I would even question whether it's
actually a good idea to to really focus
on this great game as being the dominant
dynamic of that period of time one of
the parts of that narrative is the
notion that that Russia needed to take
Central Asian territories because of the
civil war in the United States and the
the problem that that created for the
cotton market and production of cotton
material in Russia well they they
weren't expanding cotton production in
the Caucasus we were where they could
have grown cotton it doesn't seem very
very plausible that really is a major
motivator for the Russian expansion into
the region and I'm not a specialist on
this period but but those who do focus
on this more have really called into
question some of these the rationales
but one of the the key stories of the
time of course and which connects with
colonial expansion in other parts of the
world is the notion that Russia was
expanding as a civilizing force than
bringing civilization to these to these
regions what kind of civilization they
were able to bring in the 19th century
is a
bit questionable because the Russians
weren't really ready or able to invest a
great deal in in this part of the world
and as I mentioned earlier this this
part of the world really i think felt
very remote from Russia so those those
soldiers and other representatives of
the empire that were based in Tashkent
Iran Dijon felt very right exposed I
think and so when revolutionary times
came in nineteen sixteen seventeen that
things very easily got out of hand in
this region as well the Americans
started becoming interested in this
region as well and one of the most
prominent visitors to the region was a
guy named Eugene Skyler from upstate New
York and he produced a wonderful
two-volume work called turkestan notes
of a journey in Russian turkestan etc
and and it's illustrated with these
engravings which are mainly actually
drawn from from artwork of the city very
shy and some of you may know his work
Michigan was a Russian artist who
traveled with the the Russian army into
various places where they were fighting
battles and expanding the Empire and so
on and into turkestan among other places
and Skyler was a diplomat and he was
stationed in Russia for a period of time
as well as in Turkey and other nearby
places and was very interested in this
part of the world he reinforced the idea
that Russian expansion was a good thing
and the long this is actually another
painting by shagun along with with the
Russian representations of the region
suggested that this is a very wild and
and unruly part of the world that really
needs civilizing and the the Russian
impact was a positive one on the region
that's that's what he was able to
confirm to the world now the other bit
later the accounts that we get about
Central Asia come from from different
groups of people and I'll focus for a
moment on
people who originated from within the
region and eventually made their way out
of the region mostly in connection with
the revolution this guy Mustafa chick
ioffe is from Kazakhstan and a narc who
will be talking this afternoon could
tell you a lot more about him than I can
I'm sure he he was one of the leaders of
opposition to the Bolsheviks and for a
short period in 1917 led a independent
state of turkestan which eventually was
crushed by the Red Army and he fled to
the west and wrote some some works on
Central Asia which began a tradition of
writing in the west by migr scholars
which was very much of course critical
of the Russian regime the the especially
the Soviet regime and and we have even
before the beginning of the Cold War
here the emergence of a very strongly
polarized discourse about what's
happening in Central Asia in relate in
relation to the kind of rule that it has
and how that's perceived by Central
Asians and so jakaya feels very critical
of the Soviet regime and in fact in 1941
he participated in forming a turkestan
regiment that's what this little badge
is from under the the army of the Third
Reich which fought against against
Hitler's armies and incorporated at both
emma grace as well as captured soldiers
in fighting against the soviets drink
during World War two another probably
more important figure from the point of
view of scholarship is this gentleman
Zach evil ed toll on who is originally
from Bosch Kurdistan so that's up in
south central Russia but but one of the
territories which under under Soviet
rule became an autonomous territory
within Russia alongside of tatarstan so
is right next to Tatarstan and these two
groups the bhaskar's
and the Tatars are very closely related
ethnically as well and they had they had
a traditional connection with Central
Asia because they had been involved in
the the Russian Imperial project and
often were used as translators and spies
and intelligence people in the the
Russian expansion into the region they
also had a strong cultural affinity both
on the basis of Islam and Turkic
identity and in the period prior to the
revolution there had been a growth of
the such movements as the jadida Smoove
meant that is a reform movement within
Islam which extended across this region
all the way from Constantinople through
Crimea and the Tatars volca basin and
into Central Asia with with links and
exchanges of newspapers and so on well
Tolan was involved in that sort of thing
and then when the revolution came about
he also joined up against the Bolsheviks
and was a key figure also in independent
an effort to create an independent state
in turkestan in 1917 and he also
eventually fled to the west he lived in
Europe for a while and eventually
settled in Turkey and here you see one
of the books that he wrote in Turkish
about turkestan and he became one of the
major voices which presented Central
Asia to the west and he and others like
him I think were became the authors
really of that idea that we talked about
a bit earlier the idea that Central Asia
was meant to be united as a turkestan a
unified territory of Turks and and
Muslims and was unjustly divided into
separate Republic's as a method of
dividing rules I was talking about
earlier zech evil ed told on who was
very critical of the Soviet regime but
on the other hand you have figures like
this woman who I already quoted you from
this is on Lewis strong whose text i
began my presentation with and she was a
seattle labor activists and and leftist
who became
quite convinced of the the the value of
the Soviet project in the early 1920s so
in 21 through 23 she went off to Russia
soviet russia and visited Central Asia
as well and wrote a number of books
based on this including this one you see
here the growth road to the Great pamir
the pamir being the mountain range in
southeastern Tajikistan there's a yup
she also wrote one called the red star
over summer can't and these books are
filled with her encounters in the region
which are almost uniformly enthusiastic
she felt like Soviet regime was bringing
great think things to Central Asia and
bringing about the civilization and
progress in you know model but she
thought quite appealing she eventually
focused more on China and actually
joined up with Chinese revolutionaries
and died in nineteen seventy in China
having lived out her days there and but
I think she did actually become a bit
more critical about how things were
going in the Soviet territories as you
grow older as well but but you see with
these two discourses now that especially
the immigrate discourse and the
discourse of enthusiastic Westerners who
visit the region a real bifurcation two
perspectives on on central asian really
a great difficulty bringing them
together that there were some there are
some frameworks in which they come
together neatly for example the general
approval of soviet modernization the
idea that that the spread of education
for example the introduction of new
universal education and and also
literacy and also especially the the
project of an emancipation of women was
something that that emily strong was
extremely enthusiastic about and also
met approval in general in even by most
critics of the soviet union in relation
to to central asia now another
interesting figure in this picture is is
Langston Hughes who also made a visit to
censure
Lygia he was actually he had to deal
with the soviet soviet publishing are
actually film studio to make a film
about about about race relations in the
United States and for reasons which I
haven't seen well explained that that
project fell through I think that
ultimately probably his vision didn't
match with Soviet vision in some ways
but he he remained very enthusiastic
about the Soviet Union visited Central
Asia stayed for a number of months in in
in central in Soviet Union especially
Central Asia and went to Central Asia
with the expectation of finding and he
generally confirmed this that there is a
part of the world where we're dark
people are treated like equals with
other people and that that this is a
great success that the Soviet project of
the gallic arianism and and you see him
in the middle of the photo here with his
turban on he traveled around and wrote a
small book about his visit to Central
Asia which was published in Moscow I
don't think there's someone who's trying
to republish it here but I don't think
it's actually come out yet it hasn't
bitch cake how's everything how's that
right okay great and these are actually
in the face should enlarge some of these
photos but you see here a travel article
that that Langston Hughes wrote about
Central Asia afterwards so he's trying
to sell newspaper articles talking about
how how women are now dancing in
Uzbekistan which they couldn't do
previously they're happy to do that
together with men he also in the
description of this company article it
says that they're both went men and
women are able to watch this but there's
actually no women in the audience I
don't see any in them in the picture and
I'm at it I'm actually a little
suspicious this is actually not an Uzbek
woman perhaps a Russian there's a
they're the most the the person who
created is back dance is a woman who was
called Tamara Hunnam was Russian
immigrant to the region and who invented
those back dance forms for the various
parts of his
pakistan as part of the project of
creating a national culture for the
region something that that Langston
Hughes found very appealing but many of
us would tend to view more critically
today and it creates a bit of a problem
interpreting what happens when Langston
Hughes goes off to Central Asia is he's
just not seeing what's going on there of
course thousands of people were being
repressed in various forms just around
the same time as they were completing
the process of collectivization and the
thousands of people dying in the FATA in
artificial famines and so on he didn't
write about this obviously in the book
that was published in in in Moscow and I
haven't seen his any writings of his
that address this this difficult
contradiction of of seeing something
that he found very appealing obviously
but at the same time something that
raised difficult issues the the version
of the the book that I've seen is
actually in the Yale library with his
notes on it that that is that he tried
he edited the text and it's interesting
to look at the way that he wanted to
change the story that that was coming
through in officially soviet produced
publication but of course the discourses
that surround these visitors of to
Central Asia that time were the kinds of
transformations that were going on
including at that time of course very
weak movement towards industrialization
and that sort of thing but but expansion
of agricultural production and education
and so on and the role of women being
one of the major themes that is
addressed by many of the authors others
include not only the Langston Hughes and
we strong but other is kind of offending
a holla for example from Germany or
Switzerland I think and so the images of
one where the it's a movement from this
kind of situation for women where they
have no public space at all they're
enclosed even in public and what you see
here is what's called the para and ja
it's basically a defective coat it's
it's like a coat draped over
her head with with our artificial arms
that you couldn't put your arm or your
sleeves into and then your artificial
sleeves that could put your arms into
and and then a horsehair mesh that
further covers her face this is what the
Soviet project saved central asian women
from the fact is that only a very small
percentage of central asian women wore
these these outfits only the elite the
women the women of families which we're
trying to make a point of showing their
wealth by showing how they could have
their women isolated in this way but
most women had a much more public
involvement but but of course lots of
different kinds of transformations and
and Westerners were also enthusiastic
about some of these for example the
bicycle on the step and that sort of
thing and especially of course the
introduction of education of women girls
and this is indeed one of the huge
successes as many people view it of the
Soviet project when the very few people
in Central Asia would want to go back on
now even if they view other aspects of
Soviet experience negatively now the
discourse is about Central Asia and the
Caucasus that emerged in Western writing
of course it contained a lot of critical
elements and there there are two threads
of critical discourse that pertain
particularly towards Central Asia and in
some ways that rather contradictory
they're very well represented by this
figure Alexander bendixen and also his
daughter Maria roxa Benison who wrote
you could say the majority of the books
that were mean Bennigsen himself and his
co-authors wrote the majority of books
that were written about Central Asia by
anyone during this time practically that
is during during a latter part of the
Soviet period the the discourse is that
I want to highlight are on the one hand
the claim that the Soviet the Soviet
rule is very is very powerful in
totalitarian controlling and his
successfully eradicated lots of elements
of traditional culture and the things
that people value
so for example the discourse about Islam
is that it was basically completely
suppressed in most parts of the of the
Soviet Union as a measure of the the
Soviet states draconian atheistic
policies at the same time there is a a
parallel discourse that emerges in the
same writings both by Bennigsen and many
others writing about the Soviet Union
central asia during this period that is
that there is a very strong impulse of
traditionalism in the region which
resists soviet ization and so Bennigsen
himself talks about how dramatically
suppressed islam is but also how islam
is really seething under the surface and
and it poses a real danger of bursting
forth as a as a threat to the to the
stability of the Soviet Union and not
only Bennigsen but others the few people
that actually talked about scenarios for
the breakup of the Soviet Union tended
to talk about the Muslims as being the
problem it turned out that that's not
really what happened to the Muslims were
not the least they're not the most
restive members of the Soviet population
on the contrary but but that discourse
of traditionalism and opposition to
Soviet rule it emerges very strong and
that this of course underlies the kinds
of things that we were talking about
earlier that the notion of divide and
rule the question of whether the Soviet
state was allowing the nationalities to
develop themselves but by the creation
of National Republic's and promotion to
national cultures within these those
contexts or whether whether they were
ultimately being emasculated and
suppressed and leading towards ultimate
reciprocation and the way that people
think about the Soviet Union today also
it embodies this kind of contradictory
thinking that is thinking about Soviet
times and their impact on Central Asia
on the one hand suggesting that Central
Asians really are intensely traditional
and it's quite natural that they
emerged with new revival of Islam for
example and potential radicalism and so
on but at the same time the notion that
they were so dramatically transformed by
Soviet experience that they they've lost
their soul in a sense that they no
longer retain the connection with their
with their traditional cultures these
kinds of discourses appear both in local
discourses as well as in in Western
discourses about the region another
interesting figure among those who
studies Central Asia is this gentleman
Lawrence crater who is also an American
and he at just around the time of world
war two actually got some contracts with
with us intelligence wrote a book called
the Kazakhs that manual for
psychological warfare for example with
which which were aimed at telling the
American policy establishment and
military planners and so on what they
need to know about the region in order
in case we need to fight a war in that
territory and this this became one of
the dominant modes for thinking about
central asia i mean the the extent to
which central asia and the caucasus
posed a threat to the stability of the
soviet regime what we would need to know
in order to support potential opposition
to the soviet regime through through
this region and so on it's a bit ironic
though because crater himself was a
Marxist and and most of his work most of
the work that he was most proud of is
reinterpreting marks and that for
example the the Oriental mode of
production was one of the themes that he
developed and he eventually emigrated
from the United States and went to live
in Berlin because he didn't like America
I guess he had bad experiences with his
military contracts in earlier years but
but he so he injured he occupies an
interesting place in the on the one hand
sort of knowing your enemy but at the
same time being more aligned with the
reps that the Anna Louise Strong's of
the world and
and Langston Hughes okay now crater and
especially the next people that I'm
going to refer to are the people that
that dominated the field of Central
Asian Studies when I began studying the
region and there really were very few
people that studied Central Asian for
before the period of perestroika in fact
when I started on my plan to be an
anthropologist working in Central Asia
people told me well that's all very good
but you can't write a dissertation in
anthropology based on library work in
the idea that I would actually be able
to do fieldwork in Central Asia seemed
completely unthinkable at the time I
don't know why I thought I would be able
to do it seems like crazy youth to me
when I think back on it but but at that
time there there were a few scholars who
focused on Central Asia and they
occupied a number of the important
universities Edward all worth here was
at Columbia University and it's still
living in New York and I guess there was
up a conference in his honor last year I
believe still has a gathering of his
students could be brought together and
so on he was one of the important
figures who I came to meet just when I
first started out and he's actually one
of the very few who is who is a native
american a native born aboard in America
that is most of the scholars who
dominated the field at the time when i
began were migr scholars from one or
another country and i'll present a few
of those people to you in a moment but
it but it's interesting how the field
was dominated by such figures and in
addition to being Emma grades they were
also very sort of disparate in their
positions they tended to dismiss one
another as authorities they sort of had
the problem of the small field where
everybody wants to be the main figure in
it and and so most of what you'll the
people that I'll present you now most of
them if you talk to them about the other
ones they would say well then
not doing very good work and it really
made a bad situation for studying
Central Asia when I first started out
because not only were there very few
people that you could turn to but if you
turn 21 then it meant that you couldn't
really talk to the others very very
readily and and this even within
universities that created problems
because you tried to compose your your
PhD committee and this guy is not going
to let you pass if that guy likes what
you're doing so but but but one thing
that's really good about central asian
studies today is that that's not true
anymore it's really changed a very
dramatic change another of the figures
in this in this picture is Ilse sir
todas who was I think quite instrumental
in establishing Central Asian Studies at
the University of Washington in Seattle
she also is an migr of German
background and she is fiercely
anti-soviet very very strongly aligned
with the Central Asian peoples and
considers everything that the Soviet
that all the influence of the Soviet
period to be very bad at four percent
relations undermining their culture and
so on and that's a thread that runs
through a number of the people that
dominated the field when I began so
there was a very strong sort of a cold
war tinge to the study of Central Asia
when I when I first started that in
Central Asia another migr scholar a
dentist I know who was that I guess the
teacher of one of the participants here
he didn't really study the western part
of Central Asia that is the Western
turkestan the former Soviet republics
particularly he it was Hungarian by
background he actually just died a few
months ago living to a very good old age
and he at the University of Indiana so
perhaps an unlikely place for for being
the hotbed of Central Asian Studies he
established really the strongest program
for most of the late soviet period and
perhaps even till today one of the
strongest programs for the study of this
region he like other hungarians was
interested in central asia
and other things like a mensch manchus
and and Mongols and so on because of
this idea of the commonality of the Euro
Altaic linguistic family I'm not a
linguistic I'm not a linguist but I
actually don't believe the theory of of
unity it seems to me and those those
more authority people that I've talked
to about this question seems us that
that this is really a more product a
sort of romantic imagination that wants
to connect people across a very broad
region often rather in opposition to
other people so there's one of the
utilities of the URL I'll take theory is
that it creates a category which is
posed against the Russians right it's
the category that surrounds the Russians
on all sides and and and somehow can
create a sense of unity among them of
course that idea has has motivated
certain efforts to actually create some
kind of unity at various times it works
much better in the in the framework of
Turkic unity but even that has been
relatively weak so Turkey after the
breakup of the Soviet Union tried to
have greater influence in Central Asian
on the basis of the concept of turkey
community but many Central Asians of
Turkic linguistic background didn't
really want a new older brother to take
the place of the Russians once the
Soviet Union had broken up so so those
who want to unify often run into the
problem that people don't want to be
unified on the basis that there they're
being suggested that they should unify
force I know this wasn't really so much
of a political project it but it
certainly wasn't an academic empower
building project he's the one who
devised the term inner inner Asia and
that was meant to be a geographic term
that encompassed this this kind of
cultural unity also in Indiana you have
URI bagel he's actually now retired and
living in in Cambridge so my neighbor he
came rather later to to Indiana but as
signer brew older a bagel began to
assume
the prominent role he is originally from
the Soviet Union he spent five years in
a in a in the gulag for telling a bad
joke an unfortunate joke maybe a very
good joke being turned in by another
scholar so there's very bitter stories
in Central Asian field perhaps part of
this connects with some of the reasons
why people don't recognize her or
appreciate one another in the field some
extent and it's borrego like sign or and
all worth and indeed sir TARDIS all of
these people represent what I would call
a rather phylogeny list aura Cleo
oriented kind of scholarship and this is
rather in contrast to for example
Alexander bendixen hi I mentioned
earlier which it which was very much
more focused on on politics and the the
potential threats to the Soviet state
and so on but all of these scholars were
working in a context in which in order
to sell your product you really had to
say that this is useful for security
reasons and to make it relevant for the
the project of the Cold War and many of
these scholars students did go on to
work in government and other other
activities related to specifically
matters that involve the conflict
between the Soviet Union and the United
States or the West more generally and of
course this forms part of the background
for why you have some degree of some
pays a very strong degree of anti-soviet
character within the field of Central
Asian Studies of course add that the
bitter experience people like you a
bagel who actually spent time in a in a
camp and I mean he was able to emigrate
as a Jew originally immigrating to
Israel and making his way to the United
States and but all of these scholars
have tended on the one hand to try to
sell their there
expertise is relevant for policy but
really encourage their students to do
fill illogical historical work and and
there's a real divide between that
generation of scholarship and what has
emerged more recently of people working
in social sciences or humanities fields
which are much more integrated into
broader fields of scholarship not so
much concentrated on issues of relevance
to to security matters in many cases
although of course many political
analysts are still very much concerned
with that when I first came to Harvard
there were there were several of similar
figures a Joseph Fletcher had just died
before i got there who would have been
probably one of the most prominent field
people in the field altogether had he
not died very young oh my god pit stock
was my teacher of kyrgyz it was
wonderful to have him as a teacher of
crickets because he doesn't speak yes
and he speaks English with a wonderful
Ukrainian accent nobody told me stories
about for example how he he went to
Turkey illogical conferences where there
was a trick men linguist speaking about
how how the progressive influence of
Russian on the Turkmen language resulted
in Turkmen pronunciation of Russian
terms being exactly as that should be in
Russian but every example that he gave
was a contradiction but it was very
point according to brett Zack yeah so
these discourses that intertwine the
experience of studying language which
was one of the produc was also a linked
a linguist and a follow gist and
historian but also that sort of this
anti-soviet project the discourse he
eventually went on to study to establish
the or to lead the Institute of Oriental
Studies in Ukraine after it became an
independent country before coming back
to the United States where he died and
another wild figure I have to describe
him as wild another of my teachers that
Richard fry who was an expert on Iran
but also Central Asia wrote about
bukhara early medieval times but I think
he actually worked in intelligence in
the
post-war period as well I don't know
that for a fact but but but sort of a
these kind of mythical figures that
occupied the field we don't have so many
mythical figures anymore people have
become more more more normal but really
a wild man whenever he gets up and talks
he's waving his arms around and talking
about in very dramatic terms so just to
round out that this picture of the
development of Central Asian Studies
central Eurasian studies now this is a
CSS logo that central Eurasian studies
society the what you see here is
portraits of the the laugh of the
current and last three presidents of the
central Eurasian studies society so we
have a much younger generation of
scholars coming to dominate the field
and the older generation is really
receiving and I don't want to to
minimize their importance or say that I
don't appreciate what they've done but
but we the field has really changed a
lot since the breakup of the Soviet
Union now characterized by such figures
as this is scott levi who has just
elected the president he's a historian
of central asia writing about his
connections with with india and
currently writing something on the coal
ha ha made so pre pre contemporary yeah
and marian camp who wrote about the
early or writes about the early soviet
period and does oral history work and
you see Jim milward playing a wig or
instrument he's a specialist on China
and the field has become as i mentioned
much less dominated by a big
personalities that but there's a lot
more sort of broad cooperation and what
i think is most important is there's a
strong sense that in order for central
asian studies to be relevant it has to
connect not just with with sort of the
narrow theological themes that unites
fala gist sore or some policy relevant
issue but rather needs to be integrated
with broader scholarship and that this
is the big transformation that's been
taking place in the in the last
or so years that is people who have done
field work in the region and are trying
to make that relevant to research
research questions that are pertinent to
scholars inn in a much broader domain
and sort of maintaining a base within
area studies like the media central
eurasian studies society enables but at
the same time entering into dialogue
with with with disciplinary discussions
that go much much broader i'm really out
of time now and this is a good place to
stop there there are many interesting
developments in the in the post-soviet
development of the field of central
asian studies which we could perhaps
come back to in the discussion i'm sure
that vulnerable also address in their
presentation so with that I'll end thank
you